we I know you'll be a mystery on our
life Thank You leader if you good
afternoon everyone
so some guys do one apologies for
absence received from Council this
year's and I love the succeed Jack well
so I consume declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
security interest and or other interest
that's already on their register of
interesting any item on the agenda and
we draw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
counselor day on council cupid can
adequately interest them in hindsight
important cash cubic same as members of
written all board any of the
declarations now item three net minutes
of the last meeting so the minutes of
the meeting held on the 14th of may have
been circulated can we have a proposal
plea that they are a true and accurate
record Thank You councillor Powell we
have a seconder have you cast a parking
all in favor
thank you that is Carrie thank you item
four so I think just go around counts
today on how to cutely get to it
Ebru right they don't have to they don't
have to because of the nature of what
you're discussing it just a power
I think muted yourself castor Powell
thank you
and the purpose of this report is to
appoint directors to the for housing
companies in the new Housing Services
Group we we have seen most of this
before and the council gave approval its
last full meeting for the proposal for
the companies concerned that they are
holding company and three subsidiary
companies being written on housing
limited a deaf go and a trading company
and so that the the establishment of the
companies could be expedited mrs.
Steinberg became a director of all of
them my understanding issues them she's
anxious not to be a director then hand
over the reins to him to others so
that's the interesting of this paper
basically and you will see that in the
appendix and there are the names of of
those directors and unless anybody has
any questions I will straight to the
recommendation chair any comments or
questions it's important for you to the
recommendations please I will make
therefore the recommendations contained
in 6.1 and 6.2 the members outlined
independence are appointed as directors
of the for competition show and the
appointments of the non-executive
lectures do we have a seconder for that
please foster kennyon thank you very
much all in favor
thank you that is carrion so
congratulations to the new directors so
I a
they'll debate on think wise in one of
the problem Asian by composing services
during coded guarantee and which already
cabinet in past challenges things like
being saintly which referencing the
report and that was that backlog was
brilliantly clear inferences to came in
I think and the amount of hope so this
is fully detailed and quite compares of
a before as fully business the
challenges of payment and be that the
assisting businesses and supporting
businesses to reopen or remain open take
away but also a significant increase in
service requests in terms of always
regret those complaints and by that
Musial's they're the lockdown
legislation and I think the service
obviously being usually quite from
placing with regular physics and
inspections that's also provided
significant challenges to environment
and again I think they've risen to that
specifically by going to new means of
technology and regular briefings I think
found that the environment health so
it's also going to keep on the sort of
growth and business side because they
have the main contact contacts with
businesses into usually run a couple
exactly but cetera so it's helping us to
support Linux as little balling back on
track so yeah this is just a report
primarily to makes and to make that
given the changes in speaking to the
technology that we've been looking at
them to a glass ceilings that
potentially we can input that and
integrate I think the wider
environmental health we were looking at
CMS is very much changing before I just
want to play some records colleges from
able and reclamation sort of banks and
linked to violent homicidal singing
audiences Iranian for them the clinical
school question
I bet yeah thank you
and yes I echo canceller cupids comments
there about the excellent work that that
the environment environmental health
have been doing during the period of the
coming outbreak but not only that
actually for the whole year so I think
we do need to show some gratitude for
all that during that period of course
the hope would be when all of this is
over due recognition for the hard work
of all sections of the steps that played
during this time will be recognized
I'm sure the cabinet would support any
other comments or questions
that's council keeping them into the
recommendations thank you two
recommendations secondly if you gather
Dale all in favor
thank you that's carrying nine to six
then annual stages for air quality
report
I wanted councillor Cupid I know it says
in Libya Agenda Council Kenyon but don't
worry Council came in and what we're
calling that needs to give this report
so Casa Cupid please thank you and yeah
this is primarily obviously this is
primarily a useful queries about air
quality and when there are any issues in
our district and this quietly shown
environmentally we haven't got the shoes
therefore the knowledge
so any question Amy yeah and thank you
20 and 19 we're doing around air quality
and meeting them required in standard
situation and we report on it annually
all questions
Kenya Moore
obviously it does have a big overlap
with the climate change agenda and I
notice in the one of the appendices is
there's a big list of projects that does
overlap a lot with that and maybe
offline wish you never think about how
we want to structure that going forwards
yes yes you may be in your climate
change group council can could perhaps
in dissect this before maybe and look at
some things in detail and take out of
here some good practice or things for
specific work and examination then I
think that would be useful piece of work
to do okay sure Council cupids that
would support that
yes and you would current all questions
or recommendations have been moved or
anybody council cube me
we have a seconder please Thank You
councillor Powell all in favor
thank you that is carried thank you
item 7 then policy update so in
performance team corporate governance
information so new council deal yet this
is dealing with three policies that we
are being asked to approve and
previously we used to have a combined be
the management environmental information
regulations and the data tech policy
combined billion we've decided to
separate that out partly as a means of
strengthening GDP our factors so we have
a good game changing policy
during that testitude amazing policy and
enjoin overuse of surveillance systems
policy which is for those times where we
have body-worn video or CCTV for example
and we require to have leases or local
government organizations our cat is he
right and some to learning technical
questions around to the detail hopefully
will rather be report they're all
riveting read but I'm sure that who
journeys direct challenging questions
around weekly reports but other than
that are happy to whom us
recommendations that we've done all
three of the report of the policies
Thank You Council down any comments or
questions about the policies you know
all you've got to you've gotten away
scott-free cap so council there's
already proposals do we have a seconder
please thank you all in favor
thank you sir all policies and accepted
on block thank you item Ain there are no
oceans items so we move to item 9
exclusion to public I moved that the
public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion and the following
items of business you're going to
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in part one of 22 as amended
by a local government access to
information and variation order 2006 and
they are from gender items tend to with
the team we have a second over the Casa
de lor maiden and kiosk carried then the
public makes
you